Donelle told me a funny story recently
about Chappell row with Chappelle
he said they got a hold on all wrong
yeah got a hotel take a [ __ ] in here
would you Dave Chappelle you gotta take
a [ __ ] on the road just get a hotel room
and go take a [ __ ] ya don't wanna [ __ ]
in the lobby and I can get in here I
mean if I was David I would wanna
shouldn't a lobby either yeah somebody
sees you bothers you why you shittin
yeah so I just like they pulled over for
a second he took a [ __ ] and then took
your [ __ ] took a shower and came out
like yeah bro if Donna was here would go
off on me so you just in case it comes
in the future
I took a boo-boo on the tour bus so it
was the whole thing it became a whole
thing it's definitely a no-no on tour
buses and it was a situation definitely
everybody was it was so funny though the
whole I mean you can't [ __ ] in the bus
babe listen Donald Rollins was juicing
this guy in Syracuse New York was taking
out a Jew he went and bought a juicer
and was juicing all the leftover veggies
from the greenroom he had in the fridge
he was making these James putting them
in jars it's like yeah let's do this
chugging them they were decent right
there the fly brain that made you want a
[ __ ] whoo - three o'clock no more
because we left direct to Rochester
after that and things had to happen you
know I do I'm gonna ask Dave Chappelle's
tour bus to stop so I can go for me I
just in my head cuz you're going in the
Holiday Inn Lobby you're not getting
your own room yeah I mean yeah I'm gonna
be Dan somewhere I was just like oh it's
fine he's gonna empty the tank with this
what they do and everything be fine just
forget about it and that's not what
happened I never thought about levels of
fame according to where you [ __ ] but
that's the way you could really quantify
it like when you're doing good like he's
at at the level where he gets a hotel
room [ __ ] yeah I mean you could do that
now you could price lie in a room for
like 50 60 dollars in a comfortable [ __ ]
in there yeah you could yeah you could
do it yeah he's not like pull over Four
Seasons only it wasn't really that I bet
you princes though yeah
prince is going like yeah I gotta take a
[ __ ] in there like there's a hottie and
he's going I'm pretty [ __ ] the Holiday
Inn Dave Chappelle ship to the holiday
bring me [ __ ] the highest 5-star
Hotel you can find that's funny
and then he probably gets too sweet in
the 5-star Hotel shit's in there and
those walks out that was a fun tour
though that was a fun that was a fun leg
of that tour so many that was the first